Salut, moi, c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec.
Après deux épisodes axés sur la politique belge avec Frédéric Chardon de La Libre Belgique et l'écologiste Barbara Trachte, je voulais conclure cette série en beauté en parlant de politique internationale.
On avait abordé avec les deux invités précédents la montée des extrêmes un peu partout dans le monde, y compris au Brésil, aux États-Unis et maintenant en Belgique.
On avait rapidement évoqué l'importance des réseaux sociaux pour tous ces partis populistes, mais sans vraiment aller au fond des choses, sans vraiment expliquer leur stratégie.
C'est maintenant chose faite puisque dans cet épisode, je reçois l'excellent Giuliano da Empoli, qui est l'auteur d'un très bon livre à ce sujet.
Il est italien, mais rassurez-vous, cet épisode est en français. C'est vraiment un très bon épisode, donc j'espère que vous me pardonnerez mon retard et j'espère qu'il vous plaira aussi.
C'est parti. Bonjour à tous. Aujourd'hui, j'ai le plaisir d'être rejoint par monsieur Giuliano da Empoli. Giuliano, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Vous êtes directeur du think tank Volta à Milan et vous étiez auparavant conseiller politique de Matteo Renzi lorsqu'il était Premier ministre.
Et vous êtes surtout l'auteur du livre Les ingénieurs du chaos, raison pour laquelle nous vous avons invité aujourd'hui dans cette émission, qui est publié aux éditions Jean-Claude Lattès.
Mais je suis également rejoint exceptionnellement par mon très bon ami Patrick Beja. Patrick, salut.
Salut Guillaume, merci de l'invitation.
Donc tu es, pour ceux qui ne te connaissent pas, les rares, les quelques-uns qui ne te connaissent pas, tu es l'animateur du Rendez-vous Tech et de l'émission en anglais le Phileas Club.
Et c'est justement parce qu'on va parler aujourd'hui de technologie et de politique internationale que je tenais à ce que tu nous rejoignes pour cet entretien.
Alors, avant de se lancer, Giuliano, je vais vous demander, peut-être pour ceux qui ne vous connaissent pas, de vous présenter et peut-être de nous expliquer un petit peu ce que c'est Volta, votre think tank.
Oui, donc, je suis surtout un auteur d'essais sur des thèmes de société et de politique depuis assez longtemps.
J'ai commencé tôt, quand j'avais vingt-trois ans et j'ai pas vraiment arrêté depuis. Aujourd'hui, j'en ai quarante-cinq.
Et donc j'ai publié une douzaine d'essais sur plusieurs thèmes, initialement en italien et puis qui ont été traduits, dont le dernier, justement, qui a été écrit directement en français et qui s'appelle justement Les ingénieurs du chaos.
Parallèlement à ça, j'ai suivi un parcours aussi de conseil politique. Donc, j'ai été conseiller de beaucoup d'hommes politiques italiens et européens.
Et notamment, j'ai été adjoint à la culture du maire de Florence, Matteo Renzi, quand il était maire, et je l'ai depuis suivi comme conseiller politique quand il est devenu Premier ministre de l'Italie.
À partir de 2015, avec un groupe d'amis, nous avons décidé de créer un think tank, justement, basé à Milan, qui est la ville la plus dynamique d'Italie,
avec l'objectif surtout de relancer en Italie une nouvelle façon de regarder les problématiques européennes et de relancer un discours europhile.
Bon, vous me direz, ça n'a pas très bien marché vu ce qui s'est passé en Italie depuis. Donc, effectivement, nous n'avons peut-être pas produit l'effet escompté.
Et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs, peut-être, que j'ai écrit ce livre, qui s'occupe des stratégies, d'essayer un tout petit peu d'analyser les stratégies des spin doctors nationaux populistes qui sont aujourd'hui
dominants au niveau,
au niveau du moins électoral de beaucoup de pays européens.
Excellent. Mais on va plonger tout de suite alors au cœur du sujet.
Dans votre livre, vous expliquez que nous sommes entrés dans un monde post-idéologique
et que c'est en grande partie grâce à cela et au talent de ceux que vous appelez les ingénieurs du chaos, que, voilà, des figures populistes comme Donald Trump, Viktor Orbán et le mouvement Cinq Étoiles ont pu obtenir le pouvoir.
Du coup, je suis obligé de vous poser la question : qu'est-ce que ça signifie exactement en politique, ce mot post-idéologique ?
Je ne sais pas si nous sommes entrés dans un monde post-idéologique. Je pense que nous sommes en train de changer d'idéologie plutôt.
C'est-à-dire que les nationaux populistes sont en train de désarticuler l'ancien clivage,
droite-gauche. C'est vrai que, bon, il y a un philosophe allemand qui s'appelle Peter Sloterdijk, qui dit : « Il y a toujours une certaine quantité de colère à l'intérieur de toutes les sociétés.
» Et il y a traditionnellement des forces qui ont su intercepter cette colère pour construire des projets politiques dessus.
Il dit : « Traditionnellement, au cours du XXe siècle, ça a été surtout les partis de gauche, pas que les partis de gauche, mais beaucoup les partis de la gauche qui ont intercepté la colère et le désir de changement,
pour en faire des projets politiques.
» C'est vrai qu'à la fin du XXe siècle, les partis de la gauche qui se sont un peu rendus aux lois du marché, du gouvernement plutôt centriste.
C'est vrai que les partis de la gauche traditionnelle ont un peu perdu cette capacité d'intercepter la colère,
que nos sociétés nourrissent de tout temps et qui, évidemment, augmente dans des temps de crise comme ça a été le cas en Europe à partir de 2008.
Et donc, il y a de nouvelles forces qui sont apparues, qui ont su intercepter cette rage et cette colère contre le système et qui, elles, oui, ont tendance à désarticuler les vieux clivages.
Le succès des nationaux populistes, il est basé sur la capacité d'intercepter les suffrages des électeurs qui appartiennent, qui proviennent,
disons, souvent, les leaders viennent de la droite ou même de l'extrême droite, mais après, ils arrivent aussi à intercepter les suffrages d'anciens électeurs de gauche et même d'extrême gauche.
Donc, on dit qu'ils ont du succès,
les Trump, les Brexiteers, les nationaux populistes de tous bords, inclus les Italiens,
quand ils n'ont pas que les votes des fachos, mais ceux des fâchés aussi, de tous les fâchés, de tous les mécontents.
Et ça, c'est vrai, ça désarticule le vieux clivage. Après, je ne sais pas si c'est post-idéologique, parce que la force
de ces nouveaux mouvements, c'est aussi de réinjecter, si vous voulez, de l'idéologie dans les discours, hein, face
à des forces plus traditionnelles qui sont devenues beaucoup plus technocratiques, qui parlent beaucoup moins de valeurs, d'idéaux, etc.
Donc, on est encore quand même dans l'idéologie, bien souvent.
Vous nous dites qu'effectivement, il y a un mécanisme de récupération qui est pas nouveau, mais pour plonger au cœur de la différence dans les événements que nous voyons aujourd'hui,
est-ce que vous pensez que cette récupération aurait été possible sans la technologie et les réseaux sociaux ?
Ou est-ce que c'est une composante nécessaire de cette montée de cette nouvelle forme de national-populiste ? Parce qu'on a l'impression que la valeur, peut-être pas de l'idéologie, mais de la réalité,
s'est amoindrie et que c'est un facteur de l'abondance d'informations qu'on a avec les réseaux sociaux.
Donc, est-ce que-- je vous repose la question : est-ce que vous pensez que ça aurait été possible, ce phénomène, sans les réseaux sociaux ou ils sont une composante essentielle ?
Je pense qu'ils sont une composante essentielle. D'ailleurs, un livre précédent que j'avais écrit en Italie sur le Mouvement cinq étoiles s'appelait « La rage et l'algorithme ».
C'est-à-dire, à mon avis, ces nouveaux mouvements, ils se basent justement sur un socle de colère et de mécontentement qui est réel et qui dérive bien souvent de phénomènes et de problèmes réels.
Mais après, il est multiplié et canalisé, justement, par les algorithmes des ingénieurs du chaos. C'est tout le thème, d'ailleurs, du livre.
C'est-à-dire, ces mouvements ont compris,
qu'on pouvait, justement, que la rage était une ressource politique
et qu'il existe aujourd'hui des instruments beaucoup plus sophistiqués,
pour aller puiser dans les poches de rage, disons, des électeurs qui peuvent avoir d'ailleurs des causes très différentes entre elles et même contradictoires entre elles.
Mais aujourd'hui, par rapport à il y a 10, 15 ans, justement, on peut importer en politique la logique de Facebook ou de YouTube, c'est-à-dire comment ça marche.
Facebook n'a pas vraiment un intérêt à promouvoir les théories du complot ou des fake news, mais Facebook a simplement intérêt à vous garder sur sa plateforme le plus longuement possible.
Donc, le seul critère, c'est l'engagement, non. Et donc, il va vous donner exactement ce que vous voulez pour vous garder le plus longtemps sur la plateforme.
Si vous voulez des gentilles poésies de Rainer Maria Rilke, il va vous bombarder de ça. Après quelques clics, vous êtes là et puis il vous en envoie plus.
Mais si, par hasard, vous cliquez sur un thème un peu plus, disons, controversé ou un peu plus chaud, sur une fake news ou sur quelque chose, il va vous inonder de ça.
Et surtout, après, bon, il est pas tout à fait neutre, ça. On a vu ça avec les algorithmes, par exemple, de YouTube.
C'est-à-dire, oui, il vous renvoie ce que vous voulez et,
et vos préférences par rapport à vos clics,
mais en même temps, il essaye aussi de vous porter sur des contenus qui sont prouvés, qui génèrent plus d'engagement, donc plus d'excitation, plus de peur, plus de colère, plus de-- bon,
et ça, effectivement, c'est souvent des thèmes un peu, enfin, c'est des thèmes,
souvent un peu extrêmes d'un point de vue politique ou de l'information.
Ça peut être souvent des fake news. On a vu que les fake news circulent beaucoup plus rapidement sur les réseaux sociaux par rapport aux informations vraies.
Il y a eu des expériences qui ont été faites sur ça. Et donc, en effet, c'est tout à fait fondamental de pouvoir compter sur cet élément.
Après, moi, je ne veux pas faire de longues-- je parle trop, comme vous voyez, donc je vais essayer de-
C'est très bien.
Mais je vais quand même après peut-être vous raconter comment, de ce point de vue, a été conçue la campagne du Brexit, parce que c'est un peu un exemple paradigmatique de ce procédé.
Tout à fait. On viendra dans un instant à la campagne du Brexit. Effectivement, vous présentez très bien à quel point l'outil que sont les réseaux sociaux est très puissant, et en particulier pour la classe politique.
C'est un nouvel outil de marketing très puissant. D'ailleurs, la tête pensante du mouvement Cinq étoiles disait : « Nous sommes Netflix.
La partiocratie est un peu comme un vieux blockbuster » pour bien montrer, pour bien marquer à quel point la révolution numérique est marquée dans le domaine politique, tout comme dans le domaine de la vidéo.
On a très bien compris que ça cassait les vieux clivages gauche-droite. On reviendra sur le comment c'est possible, c'est très intéressant.
Mais si on comprend bien que le mouvement Cinq étoiles, par exemple, a réussi à séduire tous ces laissés-pour-compte, toutes ces personnes marquées par cette rage,
ce qui est moins clair, c'est comment il a réussi à tous les fédérer en un seul mouvement, à s'assurer que cet électorat-là
ne se divise pas en plusieurs petits partis.
Comment est-ce qu'ils ont fait ça exactement ?
Le mouvement Cinq étoiles, c'est quand même un phénomène assez fascinant et assez unique parce que c'est un peu comme
si Cambridge Analytica, au lieu d'être employé par la campagne Trump ou par la campagne du Brexit, avait fondé son propre parti et avait pris le pouvoir directement. Après,
ce n'est pas tout à fait ça, mais c'est quand même un mouvement qui naît d'une intuition d'une sorte d'ingénieur informatique qui s'appelait
Gian Roberto Casaleggio, qui comprend au début des années 2000 qu'Internet va changer la politique et qu'il va surtout falloir utiliser les données.
Mais il comprend aussi qu'on ne peut pas faire un parti purement Internet, ça ne marcherait pas comme les partis pirates de l'Europe du Nord, par exemple.
Et donc il va chez un comique qui s'appelle Beppe Grillo et lui dit : « On va faire un blog, tu seras le porte-parole de ça et moi, je serai derrière et on prendra les thèmes qui marchent mieux et on va faire ça sur Internet.
» Et en même temps, en récoltant les données, etc. Après, ça se développe, il y a de nouveaux personnages qui sortent. Toute la classe dirigeante du mouvement Cinq étoiles est recrutée à travers des sortes de casting Facebook
et ils sont testés constamment pour voir qui marche, qui ne marche pas.
Les thèmes de campagne, ça fonctionne de la même façon. On teste tout et on ne garde que ce qui génère de l'engagement. Après, dans leur cas, tout est complètement centralisé.
C'est vraiment un peu Big Brother parce qu'il n'y a aucune... Et là, c'est encore un peu le modèle Silicon Valley, si vous voulez.
C'est-à-dire, la transparence est pour tout le monde sauf pour eux-mêmes. Donc
la plateforme qui aujourd'hui s'appelle la plateforme Rousseau, sur laquelle se base
le fonctionnement du mouvement Cinq étoiles, c'est une plateforme privée qui est contrôlée aujourd'hui par le fils de Gian Roberto Casaleggio, parce que le père est mort,
donc pas open source du tout, et où sont stockées toutes les données du parti.
Et le parti n'a aucune vie dans le monde physique, c'est-à-dire il n'y a pas de réunion, il n'y a pas de congrès, il n'y a pas d'organisation territoriale.
C'est même défendu par les statuts du mouvement Cinq étoiles qui prévoit que toute la vie du parti doit se développer entièrement sur le réseau et donc sur cette plateforme Rousseau privée.
Donc, il y a eu dans l'histoire du mouvement Cinq étoiles des purges continuelles, surtout au début, quand les gens pensaient pouvoir s'organiser tout seuls, etc., on les sortait.
Et la façon de les sortir, c'était très simple. On retirait leur accès au réseau et ils étaient en dehors du mouvement. On leur retirait la possibilité d'utiliser le symbole du mouvement Cinq étoiles, qui était privé aussi.
Et puis, ils étaient en dehors du mouvement. Après, ils pouvaient toujours essayer d'organiser quelque chose dans leur coin, mais disons, ça n'a jamais vraiment marché.
Donc, c'est un mécanisme très particulier.
Après, il faut dire aussi quand même que ces mouvements, par rapport à des mouvements traditionnels avec des programmes, des idéologies, etc., ont quand même une très grande capacité partout à gérer la contradiction.
Et ça vient justement du modèle Facebook, c'est-à-dire : je vais te donner ce que tu veux, j'ai des données sur toi individuellement.
Donc, si tu es pro-animaux, c'est encore une fois le cas du référendum du Brexit, si tu es pro-animaux, je vais te dire que l'Europe ne protège pas les animaux.
Si tu es chasseur, je vais te dire que l'Europe protège trop les animaux et je vais faire ça de façon pratiquement individualisée et je vais réussir à garder dans mon mouvement des gens qui ont des opinions même radicalement opposées entre elles.
C'est ce qu'ils font justement. C'est aujourd'hui technologiquement possible. Ça ne l'était peut-être pas au temps des mass media.
Vous expliquez qu'autrefois, la politique, c'était plutôt rassembleur, plutôt on partait du centre et on essayait de rassembler un amas le plus large possible d'électeurs de gauche et de droite et qu'aujourd'hui, finalement,
on ne doit pas forcément partir du centre.
On peut dire tout et son contraire, on peut s'attaquer aux extrêmes, donc les niches que vous évoquiez, les chasseurs ou les animalistes, et que donc ça change complètement les règles du jeu.
Patrick, tu avais une question ?
Oui, qui rejoint un petit peu ce que tu disais. Vu de l'extérieur, on a l'impression que ces mouvements sont tellement contradictoires et tellement grossiers dans leurs mensonges.
On se doute bien et on comprend que les politiques et les politiciens déforment toujours un petit peu la vérité pour s'adapter à leur audience ou à leur message.
Mais vu de l'extérieur, ces mouvements ont l'air tellement de prendre tellement de liberté avec la vérité qu'il semble difficile de les suivre, enfin de tomber dans le panneau qu'ils nous affichent.
Comment est-ce que vous expliquez que ce type de--
excusez-moi, j'élabore un tout petit peu.
Ces mécanismes que vous décrivez d'hyper ciblage,
fonctionnaient peut-être, on pouvait comprendre qu'ils fonctionnent
il y a quelques années avec l'élection de Trump ou le vote du Brexit quand on ne les comprenait pas, mais aujourd'hui qu'ils ont été mis à jour, on aurait pu légitimement se dire que,
les gens qui avaient suivi ces mouvements verraient, comprendraient la supercherie et s'en détacheraient un petit peu.
Or, ce qu'on constate, c'est qu'il y a un cœur de sympathisants qui est immense dans le cas de Trump et dans le cas du Brexit, je connais moins le cas de l'Italie, mais qui ne démord pas du tout de
ces rhétoriques, même quand elles ont clairement été démontées.
Comment est-ce que vous expliquez cet aspect de ces mouvements et cet attachement à la révolte qu'ils représentent ?
Je pense que d'abord, nous vivons dans un univers d'information qui n'est plus le même qu'avant. Donc, il y a un célèbre,
un célèbre intellectuel américain qui disait : « Vous avez droit à vos opinions, mais pas à vos propres faits.
» Mais en réalité, aujourd'hui, tout le monde a droit non seulement à ses propres opinions, mais à ses propres faits.
Parce que, et ça, ça a été prouvé aussi, non ? Si vous êtes,
si vos informations, si on vous dit que les médias mentent et donc de toute façon, les mass media, c'est des élites corrompues, les journalistes, ils font partie d'un bloc de pouvoir
qui est contre le peuple.
Alors, ne vous informez pas, ne croyez pas les médias. C'était, disons, un des, une des premières choses que Trump disait au cours de ses meetings électoraux.
Et c'est un peu le leitmotiv de toutes ces formations. C'était la même chose pour Cinq Étoiles et pour tous ces mouvements-là.
Bon, alors, on ne croit pas vraiment aux médias mainstream qui, de toute façon, sont hégémonisés par les progressistes multiculturalistes, etc.
Bon. Et donc, on croit plus, on s'informe surtout, justement, sur Facebook, sur les réseaux sociaux, sur des médias alternatifs.
Et là, on sait très bien qu'après, il suffit de quelques clics pour entrer dans des réalités parallèles qui ne sont même pas nécessairement des réalités fausses.
Ce sont simplement des réalités où la hiérarchie des informations, la façon dont elles sont présentées, et vraiment ce qu'on vous raconte et ce qu'on vous raconte pas,
dépend de votre profil.
Et donc, par exemple, quelqu'un qui sera sensible au thème de l'immigration,
il va pas nécessairement être bombardé de fake news, mais disons, il a cliqué quelques fois sur des crimes commis par des immigrés légaux ou illégaux.
Bon, une fois qu'il a fait ça deux ou trois fois, chaque jour,
il va recevoir des nouvelles qui ne sont même pas nécessairement fausses, mais qui, disons, sont hors contexte parce qu'elles ne sont pas insérées dans une hiérarchie d'information normale de,
justement, de malversations et de crimes,
commis par des étrangers.
Et donc, vous entrez très rapidement dans ces bulles, que du coup ces mouvements connaissent bien et qu'ils savent très bien exploiter.
On connaît l'effort qui a été fait par Trump sur Facebook, mais on est en train aujourd'hui de voir une campagne pharaonique qu'il est en train de monter pour sa réélection,
où d'ailleurs, encore une fois, comme ça avait déjà été le cas de Obama de 2008 à 2012,
celui qui était le chef de la campagne digitale,
la fois d'avant devient le chef de toute la campagne électorale la fois d'après.
Parce qu'on comprend que c'est là que ça se joue. Et donc Brad Parscale, qui était le chef de la campagne digitale de Trump en 2016, sera le chef de toute la campagne électorale Trump de 2020.
Il est en train de monter une gigantesque machine. Et malheureusement, c'est vraiment ce processus de fragmentation de l'information aujourd'hui qui impressionne le plus. Parce que
les faits auxquels chacun de nous est exposé, même sans passer par les fake news et les complots, même en restant aux faits,
sont aujourd'hui très différents parce qu'ils sont taillés sur mesure sur la base de nos habitudes de consommation
d'informations.
Et ça vaut pour nous aussi d'ailleurs. Ça vaut pour nous aussi, parce que nous aussi, on est, disons, ceux, justement, les progressistes ou ceux qui ont une approche, disons, un peu plus traditionnelle à la
à la politique, ils sont aussi, d'une certaine façon, prisonniers d'une bulle, même si on a tendance à penser que ce n'est pas le cas.
Oui, tout à fait. Patrick, est-ce que ça répond à ta question ? Oui, oui, bien sûr. Disons que ce qui reste surprenant, et j'ai un petit peu
travaillé la question, donc je le comprends aussi, mais on peut comprendre que ce type de,
comment dire, de
manipulation fonctionne sur un petit nombre de personnes, mais quand on parle des campagnes comme celles des États-Unis et d'Angleterre, on parle de la moitié des votants, vraiment.
Et il est surprenant que cette—
parce que quand on dit : « Nous sommes aussi enfermés dans une bulle », c'est certainement le cas et je crois qu'il faut pas non plus minimiser le rôle qu'ont eu les médias traditionnels dans ce glissement,
et dans cette perte de confiance, parce qu'il y a eu des problèmes à ce niveau aussi.
Mais y a quand même une base de réalité dans ce qu'on voit chez les journalistes sérieux. Et la base des réalités est beaucoup plus ténue dans ce qu'on voit sur ces,
ces nouvelles sur Facebook, notamment, qui sont postées, les déclarations de Trump et des partisans du Brexit.
C'est quelque chose qui est vraiment clairement déformé. Et le fait que tellement de gens, qu'un petit groupe tombe dans le panneau, on peut le comprendre, mais que tout le monde tombe dans le panneau, c'est compliqué à accepter.
Mais bon, le fait est que c'est la réalité. C'est juste l'ampleur, en fait, qui est surprenante. Et ça, je continue à ne pas bien comprendre pourquoi ça a pris cette ampleur.
Ça nous dépasse un petit peu.
Mh, évidemment, ça— d'ailleurs, ça nous a tous surpris, enfin, et ça continue à nous surprendre, vu que ça continue à se produire.
Moi, je pense quand même qu'il y a une question plus politique de fond. C'est-à-dire que je pense que dans le discours national-populiste, il y a
une situation où la vérité des faits qu'ils portent et des informations qu'ils portent est moins importante pour ces électeurs que la vérité de la vision du fond. C'est-à-dire,
ils ne sont peut-être même pas dupes de toutes les informations et de tous les arguments des nationaux-populistes,
mais le discours de fond qui consiste à dire : « On a perdu le contrôle de notre destin, on n'est plus maître chez nous, on est en train de s'appauvrir et on n'a pas,
et on n'a pas vraiment les moyens pour reprendre le,
le contrôle de notre destin.
Et c'est l'ouverture qui produit ça
». Ce discours-là, il résonne
avec beaucoup d'électeurs et il leur semble profondément vrai, même si après, justement, les Boris Johnson et les Donald Trump et,
et les Matteo Salvini vont inventer des trucs absurdes ou injecter de fausses informations.
Alors que les, disons, les partis plus traditionnels, les progressistes, les pro-européens, etc.,
ils donnent des informations et des arguments qui sont tous, enfin, a priori, plus ou moins justes, prouvés, disons, basés sur des éléments de réalité.
Mais la vision d'ensemble qui consiste à dire :
« On va tous y gagner en étant plus unis, en faisant une Europe plus forte, en étant de plus en plus proches, en échangeant de plus en plus et en ouvrant de plus en plus », elle sonne fausse à ces électeurs-là.
Elle sonne, disons, pas convaincante. Ils y ont peut-être cru
pendant une certaine période et aujourd'hui, ils disent : « Mais non, c'est pas l'expérience, c'est pas mon expérience de vie, c'est pas l'impression que j'ai ».
Et donc il y a ce paradoxe-là, justement, qu'une addition de faussetés peut générer une vision qui résonne vrai,
qui résonne vrai pour certains électeurs, pour une large partie des électorats de nos pays, alors qu'une addition de faits réels produit une vision d'ensemble, une vision politique
qui sonne fausse et manipulatrice et,
à une large partie des électorats européens, américains, etc.
C'est un peu— bon, je sais pas, c'est un peu gros, enfin, comme analyse. Mais j'ai l'impression qu'il y a quand même quelque chose de ça.
Vous avez employé à plusieurs reprises le terme, voilà, une partie des électeurs, un certain électorat. Du coup, j'ai envie de poser la question : est-ce qu'on est tous égaux face à l'algorithme tout-puissant de Facebook ?
Parce que quand on vous lit, on a l'impression que ça impacte surtout, voilà, les électeurs fragilisés, qui ont une certaine rage en eux.
Est-ce qu'on est tous égaux face à cet algorithme ?
Bah, non, évidemment, on a—
bah, on voit d'ailleurs, c'est le cas même de— aujourd'hui, c'était pas le cas au début, mais aujourd'hui, si on regarde la,
la composition sociologique des utilisateurs de Facebook, ça a été beaucoup fait dans le cas des analyses du mouvement des gilets jaunes en France, par exemple.
Et il y a des analyses très intéressantes là-dessus qui prouvent,
que Facebook, c'est vraiment devenu le média de choix, de communication et d'information, de classes sociales plutôt populaires et plutôt périphériques aujourd'hui.
C'est-à-dire que, bon, et c'est d'ailleurs ce que les— encore une fois, ce que ces spin doctors savent parfaitement.
Quand le— Luca Morisi, qui est le stratège de communication de Matteo Salvini, dit : « Bon, quand on veut parler aux élites ou aux journalistes, etc., on est sur Twitter.
Mais après, la vraie communication de masse où vous, justement, vieux outils de la politique traditionnelle, vous n'arrivez pas, ça se fait sur Facebook.
» D'ailleurs, Matteo Salvini est l'homme politique européen qui a le plus de suiveurs et d'engagement sur Facebook, très loin devant les Macron, les Merkel et même tous les autres leaders nationaux-populistes.
Il est autour de 4 millions de, disons, de fans enregistrés sur sa page Facebook.
Patrick, c'est peut-être en grande partie pour ça que tu ne comprends pas bien la puissance, l'impact que ça peut avoir.
C'est parce que tu n'es simplement peut-être pas le bon électorat, Patrick.
Pas assez sur Facebook.
C'est possible. Tu ne, oui, voilà, tu ne fais pas partie de la classe populaire qui est plus fragilisée, plus sensible à ces choses-là.
C'est ça, effectivement.
Si je comprends bien.
On va prendre cette explication. Elle me sied, merci. Elle flatte mon ego. Merci Guillaume.
Super.
Mais donc oui, je— pour revenir à ce que vous disiez il y a un instant, Giuliano, donc les ingénieurs du chaos, les personnes comme Steve Bannon ou bien,
Casaleggio, qui sont donc ces personnes derrière la montée de, voilà, des figures nationales-populistes qui ont compris
comment, voilà, utiliser,
ben voilà, justement, cette rage de ce milieu populaire.
Vous dites dans le livre : « Leur ingéniosité est celle d'avoir compris que la rage était une source d'énergie colossale et que l'exploiter permettait de réaliser n'importe quel objectif.
» Alors du coup, j'ai envie de poser la question : cette rage, pourquoi est-ce qu'elle ressort aujourd'hui plus qu'avant ?
Est-ce que, de nouveau, les réseaux sociaux jouent quelque chose là-dedans ? Est-ce que ça amplifie la rage, les réseaux sociaux ?
Oui, tout à fait. C'est-à-dire, je pense, bon évidemment, il y a eu quand même au moins deux faits socioéconomiques majeurs qui se sont produits à,
entre la fin des années 0 et le début des années 10, c'est-à-dire la crise financière de 2008 et puis la crise migratoire de 2014, 2015, 2016,
qui sont des faits majeurs et qui ont contribué à multiplier la rage dans beaucoup de milieux populaires,
aux— bon, aux États-Unis, surtout en ce qui concerne la crise financière et en Europe les deux, et à discréditer les élites.
Donc, il y a là des faits réels qui ont eu— ont produit un impact politique certain.
Après, encore une fois, justement, c'est prouvé que,
disons, et d'ailleurs, là aussi, il y a des recherches assez intéressantes, par exemple, sur les zones de conflits ethniques,
où il y a une recherche sur l'Allemagne qui est passionnante, où on a croisé, justement, les données de pénétration de Facebook avec la géographie des incidents xénophobes qui se produisent sur le territoire allemand.
Et on a vu qu'il y avait quand même plus de probabilités qu'il y ait des incidents xénophobes dans les zones où la pénétration de Facebook est plus élevée.
Bon, alors, après, moi, je veux pas nécessairement— la question n'est pas nécessairement de faire un procès à Facebook, même si on sait encore une fois que
là où il y a des conflits ethniques,
où il y a des violences sectaires, ce qu'on fait
et ce que les autorités font aujourd'hui, aussi dans les pays d'Asie où,
c'est immédiatement quand il y a des explosions de violence, de fermer les réseaux sociaux et les connexions Internet, parce qu'elles propagent inévitablement des,
et très, très rapidement, des
des mots de passe, de, disons, de,
de violence, avec des fake news et elles multiplient la colère.
Je crois pas qu'on puisse aujourd'hui douter du fait que ces instruments sont des instruments qui multiplient la colère et la frustration.
C'est vrai. Ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut les fermer. Je veux dire, c'est pas, parce qu'ils multiplient aussi les possibilités de connexion, de communication, de solidarité.
On a tous été, justement, on a— personne d'entre nous n'a vu le potentiel négatif de ces instruments parce qu'on était tous tellement contents au début que
Internet fasse élire Obama aux États-Unis, qu'Internet facilite les révolutions du printemps arabe dans les pays de l'Afrique du Nord, etc.
Donc, justement, il y a plusieurs aspects. Mais c'est vrai qu'on a sous-estimé, je crois, de façon un peu
optimiste, les effets quand même de multiplication de haine que ces instruments permettent.
Excellent. 'Fin non, pas excellent, tragique, au contraire. Mais votre réponse est excellente.
Mais donc, au final, pour reprendre un petit peu tous les éléments,
la tactique de ces ingénieurs du chaos, dans le cas du Brexit, c'était donc comprendre pourquoi ces gens, donc, voilà, vous disiez principalement un électorat,
pas seulement, mais principalement un électorat, voilà, plutôt les classes populaires fragilisées,
et plutôt sur Facebook donc, comprendre pourquoi ces gens-là sont énervés.
Et ensuite, dans un deuxième temps, utiliser les messages ciblés sur les réseaux sociaux pour leur dire : « Voilà, c'est à cause de l'Union européenne
qu'il faut voter, euh, pour le— soit voter pour le Leave, soit rester à la maison et ne pas aller voter pour le Remain.
» Et pourquoi pas, occasionnellement, en utilisant, voilà, des fake news. Et du coup, qu'est-ce que les ingénieurs du chaos emploient comme outil pour, voilà, comprendre des patterns et cibler certains électeurs ?
Ben voilà, alors,
le procédé de Cambridge Analytica, il se base sur les recherches d'un ingénieur russe qui est, ben, basé à Stanford depuis longtemps et qui fait des profils psychographiques sur la base de vos likes Facebook.
Et lui, ce qu'il a fait d'assez intéressant, c'est qu'il a prouvé, bon, ou du moins, il a fait des recherches qui disent que sur la base de 30— si vous posez à quelqu'un,
mettons, je veux savoir, je suis ami de Guillaume et on me pose un questionnaire de questions relativement privées sur les goûts, les préférences,
les inclinations de Guillaume.
Alors, cet ingénieur russe a démontré que sur la base de 30 likes sur Facebook, il savait répondre à ce questionnaire mieux qu'un ami de Guillaume.
Sur la base— non, qu'un collègue de travail de Guillaume. Sur la base de 60 likes, il savait répondre mieux qu'un ami de Guillaume.
Sur la base de, je crois, 150 likes Facebook, il pouvait prévoir et connaître les goûts et les réponses de Guillaume à ce questionnaire personnel mieux qu'un conjoint ou qu'un membre de la famille.
Et 300 likes Facebook permettaient de répondre mieux que le conjoint, l'épouse ou le conjoint de la personne.
Et donc, on voit 300 likes sur Facebook, c'est rien. Je veux dire, c'est une semaine d'activité, même pas. Enfin, après, ça dépend de votre taux de participation.
Et Cambridge Analytica, ça se base sur ça. C'est-à-dire, ça se base— on va récolter, il paraît d'ailleurs de façon illégale, des données sur des usagers, des millions d'usagers Facebook.
Et puis, on va construire des profils psychographiques qui vont nous permettre, justement, de cibler de façon extraordinairement précise chacun des usagers.
Et c'est— mais ça,
requiert une—
la gestion d'une quantité immense de données. C'est pour ça que Dominic Cummings, le,
le directeur de la campagne du Leave pour le Brexit, a dit dans une série d'interviews qu'il a faite après : « Si vous voulez gagner des élections aujourd'hui, vous avez— n'employez pas des experts de communication politique
ou de marketing électoral.
Employez des physiciens », parce que c'est un travail de physicien, c'est un croisement de données continu avec des masses de données que les hommes politiques et les experts de politique ne sont pas du tout habitués à gérer,
mais qui permet d'optimiser de façon systématique les messages qui sont envoyés aux uns et aux autres pour avoir le maximum de pénétration et de succès
dans ce qu'on veut leur dire.
Et donc, justement, pour les démotiver,
si c'est des électeurs qui ont plutôt tendance à être de l'autre côté ou au contraire, plutôt pour motiver ses propres électeurs, mais justement, avec des messages qui peuvent être parfaitement contradictoires entre eux.
Très bien, oui. Mais du coup, je pense que ça explique encore une fois l'incompréhension de Patrick tout à l'heure. Il se dit : « Mais tiens, mais comment est-ce que ça peut être aussi puissant ?
» Mais je pense que voilà, il y a cette réalité assez sombre, mais qu'il va falloir accepter, qui est que nous ne sommes finalement, nous, humains, nous ne sommes que des amas de données.
En tout cas, on peut être résumé à des amas de données plutôt.
Et que oui, avec des outils de big data, des outils de statistiques, des outils de machine learning, on peut finalement nous résumer, nous comprendre très simplement, comprendre nos fonctionnements.
Et voilà, l'exemple que vous donniez tout à l'heure avec cet ingénieur russe à Stanford est tout à fait parlant. Mais donc, du coup, est-ce que ça répond à ta...
Est-ce que ça explique un petit peu mieux ton— voilà, le phénomène que tu avais du mal à comprendre ? En tout cas, tu avais du mal à comprendre que ça puisse être aussi puissant.
Oui, il y a quelque chose qui reste quand même un petit peu mystérieux, c'est-à-dire que comme tu le disais en début d'émission, moi, je produis une émission en anglais où je vais justement parler à des gens
qui sont d'opinions très différentes de la mienne, dans une démarche qui, je crois, manque
dans les médias classiques.
Et j'ai donc parlé à des gens qui ont voté pour Donald Trump, j'ai parlé à des gens qui sont partisans du Brexit.
Et il y a quand même une sorte de décalage entre ce qu'ils disent et— j'ai presque envie de dire la réalité.
Je les comprends mieux, mais quand on—
je crois qu'un élément dont on n'a peut-être pas encore parlé, c'est le rejet de la classe politique en général et la situation économique du pays dans son ensemble, sans cause précise, sans explication rigoureuse.
Et là, peut-être qu'on rejoint l'aspect populiste de ces mouvements qui est que malgré tout, derrière toutes ces
toutes ces fake news et tout ce ciblage, il y a un message politique un petit peu plus traditionnel, comme vous le disiez en début d'entretien, Giuliano,
qui est d'offrir une solution simple aux frustrations que ressentent ceux qu'on appelle souvent les laissés-pour-compte de la mondialisation.
Et je crois que s'il y a une explication sur le squelette des motivations de ces gens-là, je crois qu'elle est peut-être, à mon avis, à chercher là.
Et ensuite, ces mouvements-là rajoutent les organes, on va dire, pour continuer avec cette analogie douteuse, avec les fake news et avec le ciblage. Mais
cet élément, moi, j'ai parfois tendance à l'oublier, mais y a quelque chose de très vrai, et une frustration réelle avec des gens qui, au final, sont
emportés dans un tourbillon de fake news et de ciblage qui font qu'ils vont peut-être se dire : « Bon bah allez, je m'en fous.
De toute façon, ce qui est important, c'est ma conviction de base à laquelle répondent ces mouvements.
» Et donc, bah, qu'est-ce qui— quoi qu'il se passe ailleurs, tout devient du bruit, le vrai, le faux, l'inventé, la fake news.
Et donc, je reviens à ce message simple à comprendre,
de ces populistes qui va me motiver plus que tout le reste. Et je crois que c'est en substance une grande partie de ce que vous disiez, Giuliano, mais on a tendance à le perdre de vue,
quand on essaye d'étudier le phénomène dans le détail. Et—
Oui
...et pour moi, c'est ça qui compte beaucoup aussi, quoi.
Je suis tout à fait d'accord. C'est-à-dire, et c'est un peu, si vous voulez aussi, la difficulté et l'ambiguïté d'écrire un livre comme celui que j'ai écrit et de parler de ces thèmes.
C'est-à-dire, je pense que tout ça,
ça joue un rôle très important, le ciblage, et cetera, et que justement, il y a des réalités, des pratiques qui ne sont peut-être pas suffisamment connues et
qui pèsent de plus en plus sur les résultats et sur le jeu politique.
Mais en même temps, justement, je suis vraiment, vraiment convaincu qu'il y a un problème politique à la base qui est beaucoup plus large et qui explique de façon beaucoup plus convaincante,
ce qui s'est produit et ce qui continue à se produire.
Justement, dit de façon grossière, je crois que, disons, que les... mais c'est le cas, par exemple, de la construction européenne.
On voit très bien que la construction européenne marche très bien pour,
les mobiles, pour les nomades, pour tous ceux, entreprises ou personnes qui peuvent bouger, que ce soit pour des raisons professionnelles ou même simplement pour du plaisir, pour du tourisme, et cetera.
Et toute cette construction-là, on le voit, et ce n'est pas un effet de propagande populiste ou national-populiste.
Cette construction-là, elle marche moins bien, elle sert moins bien les intérêts et elle donne moins de satisfaction aussi d'un point de vue symbolique, culturel, de reconnaissance et tout ça, aux sédentaires, si vous voulez.
C'est-à-dire aux gens qui restent d'ailleurs une large majorité de la,
de la population européenne, qui habitent toujours près d'où ils sont nés,
dans un... je crois que 70 % des Européens vivent à l'intérieur d'un périmètre de 30, 40 kilomètres de l'endroit où ils sont nés ou peut-être même où sont nés leurs parents. Et,
et là, ce n'est pas... et justement, ce n'est pas un effet de manipulation. Il y a quand même quelque chose de profondément,
de très profond, qui après peut être exploité, là, c'est vrai, de façon cynique et tout à fait,
et tout à fait,
comme ça, disons, sans états d'âme, des entrepreneurs et des ingénieurs du chaos.
Mais on l'a dit dans le cas du Brexit, c'était un sentiment qui a battu un raisonnement. Et... mais la politique, ça a toujours été ça.
Si vous pensez que vous allez pouvoir,
gagner des élections et emporter des grands mouvements,
sur la base simplement d'argumentations, de raisonnements en disant : « Non, mais là, écoutez, si vous votez contre, on va perdre des emplois, ça va être pire », c'est peut-être vrai,
mais si le sentiment est de l'autre côté, et il y a quand même cette sensation de perte de contrôle sur leur destin, par rapport à laquelle, en effet, la réponse de la fermeture est la plus logique, hein.
On va revenir dans un monde où on contrôlera nos frontières, où les entreprises ne vont pas pouvoir partir, où les capitaux ne vont pas pouvoir circuler, où les étrangers vont pouvoir entrer avec plus de difficultés, tout ça.
Bon, en réalité, on a vu que ce n'est pas vrai, non ? Je veux dire, ça ne marche pas comme ça. Et aujourd'hui, le,
la Grande-Bretagne est probablement dans une position de plus grande faiblesse par rapport à avant.
Mais c'est un argument quand même extraordinairement efficace. Et tant qu'on n'aura pas des arguments aussi efficaces d'un point de vue politique, culturel, économique, à,
à faire peser de l'autre côté, on va continuer à voir ces mouvements se développer, je crains.
Mais du coup, j'ai envie de poser la question de la solution. Puisque dit comme ça, on a l'impression que pour résoudre cette situation, il faut élever le niveau d'éducation de la population, hein.
On parlait dans l'épisode précédent d'éducation aux médias, d'apprendre à se méfier des messages ciblés, à vérifier ses sources, à ne pas croire tout ce qu'on lit sur Internet.
On se dit aussi qu'il faut sans doute, voilà, travailler à diminuer les inégalités, hein. Vous évoquiez tout à l'heure la crise des subprimes.
Bref, donc tous des travaux qui vont prendre, mais des générations et des générations, des décennies.
Est-ce qu'on est donc condamnés à subir cette montée des populismes ou bien est-ce qu'il existe une solution ?
Oui, moi, je... bon, alors, Gramsci disait quelque chose comme le pessimisme de la réalité et l'optimisme de la volonté, hein, quelque chose comme ça.
Alors, je suis dans l'optimisme de la volonté, mais non, le pessimisme de la raison et l'optimisme de la volonté, c'était ça.
Et donc, il y a quand même des précédents, justement. Bon, c'est un peu banal, mais c'est vrai que ce qu'a fait Franklin Delano Roosevelt aux États-Unis, au début des années 30,
ça a été de combiner,
une véritable révolution des politiques publiques, le New Deal, etc., pour répondre à la crise de 29, avec une révolution technologique,
pas seulement l'utilisation de la radio, qui a été un extraordinaire véhicule des nationaux-populistes, enfin des nationalistes plutôt, en Europe.
On sait que les nazis, par exemple, une des premières choses qu'ils ont faites en Allemagne, ça a été de,
d'introduire une radio dans toutes les maisons allemandes, de produire des radios qui coûtaient très peu et qui permettaient de faire entendre les voix de Hitler et de Goebbels dans tous les foyers.
Donc, ces médias-là, qui ont été de gros véhicules de pénétration du nationalisme,
et même du fascisme et du nazisme, aux États-Unis, Roosevelt les a utilisés dans une direction contraire et aussi, justement, des nouvelles techniques.
Les sondages, c'était nouveau à l'époque. C'était utilisé par les marques, les entreprises privées, mais ça n'existait pas en politique.
Et Roosevelt a introduit toute une série de nouveaux instruments, les sondages, là aussi, déjà, des instruments de ciblage,
d'interprétation de l'opinion publique et puis de communication beaucoup plus sophistiqués, par rapport à ce qu'il y avait avant.
Et il l'a fait pour contrer la montée du nationalisme et des populismes américains. Donc, c'est des opérations qui combinent des réponses politiques véritables sur la réalité
avec des réponses technologiques de marketing et de propagande,
qui ont été... c'est des opérations qui ont été faites dans le passé.
Et franchement, je ne vois aucune raison pour laquelle ce ne serait pas possible aujourd'hui. Enfin, il faut évidemment un peu plus de courage, d'initiative et de talent politique.
Encore une fois, l'exemple d'Obama est quand même un exemple...
Bon, après, c'est vrai que ça a débouché sur Trump, mais c'est vrai aussi que si Obama avait été candidat une troisième fois, face à Trump, tous les éléments que nous avons nous disent qu'Obama aurait gagné.
Alors après, ça se joue encore beaucoup. D'ailleurs, le leadership politique, on n'en a pas parlé jusque-là, mais ça reste un facteur et ça devient de plus en plus.
Après, c'est pas que positif non plus, c'est un peu inquiétant aussi. Mais disons, le leadership politique joue un rôle extraordinaire.
On a vu en Nouvelle-Zélande
le même parti changer, qui était très bas dans les sondages, le Parti travailliste, quand il a changé à un mois des élections, le leader, en gardant toute la proposition politique, le programme précédent,
il a eu un boost de 25 % et c'est Jacinda qui a gagné les dernières élections politiques et c'était simplement un visage nouveau et un leadership nouveau.
Donc, il y a énormément de facteurs qui entrent en jeu et c'est vraiment pas le moment d'être résigné ou pessimiste, hein.
De ça, je suis assez convaincu.
Patrick, tu avais une question ?
Ben, j'en aurais mille. Mais je me pose une question qui est peut-être un tout petit peu hors propos, mais on a la chance de vous parler, donc je vais quand même la poser.
On a parlé de différentes figures politiques qui ont bien utilisé les réseaux sociaux et qui ont un certain charisme.
Moi, étant français et étant un petit peu, on va dire poliment, intrigué par la figure de Jean-Luc Mélenchon, je ne sais pas si vous connaissez bien le personnage.
Il y a certaines similarités. Je veux pas dire... quand je parle de la France insoumise, parfois, j'utilise le qualificatif qui...
d'extrême et souvent, mes camarades et mes auditeurs me le reprochent en disant que ça caricature le mouvement de la France insoumise, ce que je peux comprendre,
mais je crois qu'il y a certaines similarités.
Il y a certains éléments de, comment dire, de militantisme, on va dire... bon, je vais pas utiliser le terme extrême, donc je vais me concentrer sur ma question plutôt.
Quelle similarité est-ce qu'il y a réellement entre un personnage comme Jean-Luc Mélenchon, qui a, malheureusement pour lui, qui est passé un petit peu au second plan, en particulier avec le mouvement des Gilets jaunes.
Mais il y avait quand même, je crois, une comparaison faisable avec les mouvements dont on parlait.
Oui.
Est-ce que c'est moi qui interprète les choses-
Non
...ou est-ce qu'il y a effectivement quelque chose là-dedans ?
Non, non, moi, je partage tout à fait votre avis. Je pense que lui, il a essayé de faire avec La France insoumise
une opération, justement, qui allait dans la direction d'un populisme pur, c'est-à-dire qui se détachait du clivage idéologique traditionnel, il a bien vu.
C'est d'ailleurs la théorie de Steve Bannon, l'ancien spin doctor de Trump, qui dit : « Encore une fois,
les populistes gagnent là où ils arrivent à unir populistes de droite et populistes de gauche.
» Et donc à réorganiser le clivage politique, à déstructurer le clivage droite-gauche. Et Mélenchon, qui partait de la gauche,
on a bien vu au cours des élections successives qu'il a essayé d'évacuer un peu ou de mettre au second plan, justement, le profil idéologique, l'être de gauche, etc.,
ou en mettant au premier plan plutôt, justement, la colère de tous bords, les exclus, les oubliés, etc.
Et donc on ne prend plus vraiment parti entre Le Pen et Macron quand il s'agit de donner une indication au second tour.
Et donc, on essaye et on courtise et on essaye de récupérer le mouvement des Gilets jaunes qui lui-même contenait beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup d'éléments différents.
Et bon, il a... on voit bien qu'il a essayé de faire ça parce que c'est une opération qui reste à faire en France, justement.
En Italie, elle a été faite grâce surtout au Mouvement 5 étoiles qui après a pu devenir le véhicule pour une vraie droite en même temps, parce que Salvini, c'est quand même,
c'est quand même une droite assez radicale, mais il n'aurait jamais pu prendre le pouvoir sans la contribution décisive du Mouvement 5 étoiles qui, du coup, est un mouvement post-idéologique, purement populiste, etc.
Et cette opération-là, elle reste à faire en France. Elle est tout à fait possible parce que Macron a fait l'opération inverse, c'est-à-dire que lui, il a gagné justement en déstructurant le clivage droite-gauche,
mais sur la base d'un programme,
europhile, d'ouverture, etc.
Et donc, il y a tout à fait la place et je crois que ça, Mélenchon l'a bien vu, pour quelqu'un qui réussirait à fédérer tous ceux qui sont du côté opposé de ce nouveau clivage
ouverture, fermeture, élite, populiste, etc.
Simplement, il n'a pas réussi à le faire. Bon, il avait probablement un peu trop d'histoire derrière lui.
La question de l'immigration reste centrale, c'est-à-dire que c'est vrai que cette union-là, elle se fait sur la question de l'immigration aussi.
Donc, tant que vous ne voulez pas,
disons, casser le tabou, qui est un tabou, disons, plutôt de la gauche traditionnelle, qui est plutôt pour une politique d'accueil, pour une politique bienveillante par rapport à l'immigration et tout ça,
là, pour faire l'opération nationale-populiste, il faut sur ça prendre une position beaucoup plus de droite, si vous voulez, hein, beaucoup plus.
Et ça, il l'a pas tout à fait fait non plus. Il pouvait peut-être pas, hein.
Oui, je crois que-
Et donc,
Ça aurait été compliqué par rapport à sa base, effectivement.
Voilà. Et mais il a tout... je pense qu'il a essayé, hein, il a vraiment essayé de faire l'opération dont vous parlez.
Mmh. Moi, ça me rassure un petit peu sur l'analyse que j'avais de, ben, des dernières élections et du personnage, parce que
comme je le dis, je pointe des similarités, sur la forme, pas, évidemment, pas sur le fond, mais sur la forme, entre Jean-Luc Mélenchon et la France insoumise et ce qu'on voit du côté droite dans différents pays.
Et souvent, on me répond avec un petit peu de violence que je suis alarmiste et que j'essaye de salir l'image de Mélenchon et ce genre de choses.
Donc ça me rassure un peu que sans juger le fond, encore une fois, vous me confirmiez que vous avez une analyse, en tout cas, un petit peu similaire.
Donc merci de m'indiquer que je suis pas complètement fou.
On se trompe peut-être tous les deux, mais enfin, je-
C'est possible, bien sûr
...je suis d'accord avec vous sur ça, tout à fait, ouais.
D'accord.
On n'en a pas parlé, mais l'aspect populiste de la France insoumise apparaît aussi quand on regarde le fait qu'ils ont lancé leur propre média qui s'appelle Le Média.
Et voilà, et on retourne un petit peu à ce qu'on disait sur la radio dans la maison, pour, en Allemagne.
C'est... il y a le côté contrôler l'information et voilà, présenter les choses sur un certain angle.
Oui, ça s'inscrit dans... j'ai pas donné d'exemples concrets, mais effectivement, ça s'inscrit dans cette mouvance où on ne peut pas faire confiance aux médias, effectivement.
Et si vous allez voir les gens du Média, puisqu'ils s'appellent Le Média, ils vous assureront et vous jureront jusqu'à leur dernier souffle qu'ils n'ont rien à voir avec la France insoumise, et que ça s'est fait de manière séparée.
Bon ensuite, on laissera chacun juger, mais oui, je voulais juste le préciser parce que je pense que tu recevras des mails sinon, Guillaume.
Selon eux, ils sont indépendants.
On va dire ça. Mais donc, on a parlé jusqu'à présent d'une stratégie qui consiste à bombarder les électeurs indécis de messages ciblés.
C'est pas la seule, hein, on a parlé de l'importance du leadership, par exemple.
J'étais tombé il y a quelques années sur un article très intéressant où l'auteur avait fait des calculs statistiques de grande échelle, hein, on parlait tout à l'heure de big data, mais c'est exactement ça.
Des calculs de grande échelle pour calculer les intersections entre les différents subreddits, donc les sections du site Reddit qui est très populaire, surtout aux États-Unis.
Et on voyait par exemple qu'il y avait un segment conséquent, c'est pas la majorité, mais un segment conséquent des visiteurs du subreddit de Donald Trump
qui postaient régulièrement, par exemple aussi sur 4chan ou sur un subreddit qui s'appelait FatPeopleHate, donc qui incitait à la haine des personnes en surpoids.
Ou encore aussi sur un subreddit qui prônait la haine raciale. C'était très parlant. Je savais pas vraiment poser de mots là-dessus.
Je ne savais pas vraiment l'expliquer, mais ça me semblait juste. C'était très parlant et donc les données le confirmaient.
Et en plus de ça, on voyait aussi que quand on faisait l'intersection des visiteurs du subreddit Donald Trump avec la communauté des gamers, une partie importante de,
de l'intersection qu'on obtenait à ce moment-là, c'était des supporteurs de ce qu'on appelle le Gamergate.
Oui.
Alors, Patrick, je suis désolé de te faire ça, mais tu avais écrit il y a quelques années un excellent article sur ton blog qui parlait du Gamergate.
Du coup, avant d'écouter Giuliano à ce sujet, est-ce que tu peux rappeler à nos auditeurs ce que c'est en fait Gamergate ?
Oui, bon, on va-
Je suis désolé hein
...on va essayer d'être... Non, non, mais je vais... C'est très compliqué en fait. C'est vraiment un mouvement compliqué qui était, tu as raison, le précurseur peut-être de ce qu'on a vu arriver par la suite, d'une certaine manière.
Gamergate est un mouvement sans leader qui a été lancé sur Internet, principalement sur 4chan et Reddit,
dont l'étincelle a été un scandale qui avait à voir avec des journalistes et, enfin une femme journaliste et des relations qu'elle aurait pu avoir avec,
un développeur et le travail qu'elle avait fait, journalistique, sur les jeux du développeur.
Et ça a donné lieu à-
Attends, est-ce que tu parles de Zoë Quinn ?
Oui, tout à fait.
Ben donc, Zoë Quinn, c'était la développeuse et c'était une relation avec un journaliste.
Excuse-moi, j'ai fait l'inverse. Mais donc le mouvement s'est articulé autour de ce premier scandale pour se développer en argumentaire anti-journalistique,
qui voulait expliquer à la communauté des gamers que les journalistes ne savaient pas faire leur travail.
Sauf que l'intégralité ou on va dire l'immense majorité de leurs critiques s'adressait systématiquement à des femmes, femmes développeurs, femmes journalistes, etc., etc.
Et il y avait ce double discours qui était impossible à,
à dédire où les gamergateurs qui s'autodéclaraient gamergateurs disaient : « Nous, nous voulons protéger le journalisme dans le monde du jeu vidéo et l'intégrité éthique et artistique du monde du jeu vidéo.
» Et dans les faits, toutes leurs critiques et toutes leurs attaques, qui sont devenues assez violentes par la suite, s'orientaient vers des femmes.
Donc c'était effectivement un mouvement clairement sexiste, qui a été parsemé de harcèlements assez terribles, qui prenait comme étendard l'éthique dans le monde du journalisme du jeu vidéo.
Et là où c'était vraiment notable, c'est qu'il n'y avait pas de leader et il y avait ce... C'est même comparable au mouvement d'Occupy Wall Street du début des années 2000, où n'importe qui pouvait se dire,
membre du Gamergate.
Et donc quand on essayait de reprocher quelque chose au mouvement Gamergate, chacun pouvait honnêtement dire : « Ah oui, mais vous prenez un exemple, il ne nous représente pas.
» Sauf que, de fait, ils avaient activement décidé de ne pas avoir une liste de demandes, de ne pas avoir de hiérarchie, de structure.
Et donc il était impossible de pointer du doigt les dysfonctionnements ou les problèmes du mouvement, puisque à chaque fois qu'on en pointait un du doigt, ils disaient : « Ah oui, mais il y a des extrêmes partout.
» Donc c'était un mouvement très intéressant dont on a
souvent pensé qu'il était un épiphénomène au niveau de l'histoire et on se rend compte aujourd'hui qu'il est devenu une sorte de template standard pour de nombreux autres mouvements de ce type.
Je sais pas si le résumé correspond à ce que tu espérais.
C'est un résumé très efficace.
Merci.
Et donc du coup, je me retourne
vers Giuliano, puisque vous en parlez dans le livre. Comment est-ce que les ingénieurs du chaos, Steve Bannon, Milo Yiannopoulos, pour les citer,
comment est-ce qu'ils ont fait pour dompter alors cette rage, ben voilà, on disait un petit peu anti-journalistique, surtout misogyne ?
Comment est-ce qu'ils ont fait pour dompter cette rage et la convertir en électorat, au profit de Donald Trump ?
Ça s'est concrétisé comment exactement ? Comment est-ce qu'ils ont fait ça ?
Ben là encore, c'est assez fascinant. C'est-à-dire, d'abord, ils ont, Bannon, par rapport à
tous les autres spin doctors politiques, a quand même compris avant qu'il y avait là un potentiel politique extraordinaire parce qu'il avait une expérience.
Il avait tenté de monter une entreprise basée à Hong Kong qui exploitait fondamentalement qui était basé sur le jeu World of Warcraft
Du gold farming, donc c'était pour collectionner des objets dans le jeu et les revendre pour du vrai argent
Il faisait jouer des employés chinois à très bas coût pour revendre leurs trophées aux riches joueurs américains et européens qui n'avaient pas le temps ou l'envie de passer toute leur journée sur
l'ordinateur pour gagner des trophées.
Et là, vu que c'était de la triche, en réalité, pour les vrais joueurs de World of Warcraft, il y a eu une rébellion très violente des gamers contre lui qui a forcé l'entreprise à
fermer et qui a forcé le développeur de World of Warcraft, justement, à changer les règles pour rendre impossible ce type d'opération.
Et donc là, Bannon a vu qu'il y avait des centaines de milliers de
personnes déconnectées, enfin pas nécessairement, enfin distribuées un peu partout et dont on ne connaissait pas le potentiel politique, mais qui pouvaient être un mouvement très efficace sur Internet.
Et il s'est souvenu de ça quand il est devenu responsable de la campagne de Trump. Et donc, il a embauché,
même avant, quand il était à Breitbart News, son média sur Internet, il a embauché Milo Yiannopoulos, qui était cette sorte de blogueur anglais très transgressif, qui avait essayé un peu, voilà, Patrick le disait, le
Gamergate n'avait pas de leader ou de porte-parole, mais il y avait quand même quelques personnages qui essayaient un tout petit peu d'interpréter cette mouvance-là et de se présenter comme
les porte-paroles des gamers et tout.
Yiannopoulos, c'était effectivement l'une des égéries, enfin l'un des égéries du mouvement Gamergate. C'est là qu'il a effectivement commencé à devenir particulièrement visible, on va dire.
Et donc ce qu'ils ont fait justement, c'était pratiquement de dire,
d'avoir l'argument : « Ben nous, on défend la,
d'abord la liberté des gamers et, d'une certaine façon, l'éthique du monde des gamers, justement, face à des intrusions de politically correct, de censure, de, justement,
souvent représentées par, curieusement, par des femmes.
On défend la liberté de parole, de dire ce qu'on veut et donc surtout d'insulter et, justement, d'avoir tous les comportements.
On défend le Far West, la souveraineté du Far West digital. » Et ça, ça a résonné
avec le monde des gamers auxquels ils ont expliqué justement que Trump, c'était ça, c'était contre le politically correct, ça allait préserver leur
écosystème et leur liberté face à la censure introduite par le politically correct, les progressistes, Hillary, évidemment, et tout ça.
Et ils ont pu mobiliser quand même la force de frappe de ce monde qui est justement constitué par des centaines de milliers, peut-être des millions de personnes qui sont très actives
en ligne et qui ont contribué à viraliser la campagne Trump,
à la porter dans beaucoup de milieux, à créer des mèmes, donc, disons, des slogans, des images, des fake news quelquefois, ou même avec des rappels.
Bon, on a vu ça pendant la campagne. Il y a eu quand même de la symbologie, disons, qui va du Ku Klux Klan à d'autres mouvements xénophobes,
et parafascistes qui ont fait leur apparition dans la campagne Trump, mais toujours, comme le disait encore une fois Patrick, avec la possibilité, la deniability absolue.
C'est-à-dire, si après quelqu'un dit : « Ah, mais vous, vous employez ces arguments-là », c'est qui, nous ? Hein, il y a pas, non, il y a pas de,
il y a pas de hiérarchie, il y a pas de-- donc c'est des individus isolés, ça nous représente pas et tout ça.
Et ça a été quand même,
ça a été quand même un élément assez important de la campagne Trump sur Internet, tout ce monde des subreddits dont vous parliez, des gamers, de ces forums, forums douteux, 4chan, 8chan, etc.
Oui, donc une fois que ça c'est fait, est-ce que c'est vraiment efficace ? Est-ce que c'est vraiment utile d'avoir
une armée, ben voilà, de toutes les plateformes que vous avez citées, une armée, entre guillemets, de gamers énervés ?
On a du mal à comprendre exactement comment ça peut avoir un poids à l'échelle nationale, en fait.
Ben ça a un poids à plusieurs niveaux. Parce que d'abord, vous savez, même pour toute idée, même extrême, sur le réseau, le critère de vérité, c'est le nombre, hein.
Il y a pas le vrai critère qui compte, c'est le nombre, le nombre de retweets, le nombre de likes, le nombre de-
C'est celui qui crie le plus fort qui a raison.
Et donc, tout ce monde-là, il donne une première force, une masse critique à des idées même
qui auraient été inaudibles dans le passé, parce que justement, elles ne seraient pas passées dans la presse traditionnelle, dans les médias et tout ça,
mais qui ont commencé à avoir de la traction sur Internet
Et quand vous commencez à avoir un certain nombre, une certaine masse qui se développe,
sur, autour d'une idée ou d'un message sur Internet, la masse, elle peut provoquer ce qu'on appelle une cascade informationnelle, c'est-à-dire justement, après, elle se multiplie.
Et les barrières de résistance, même de personnes qui sont du coup moins extrémistes, qui ont,
disons, des idées plus modérées, qui n'auraient jamais peut-être pensé de pouvoir ouvertement formuler une idée xénophobe ou sexiste et tout ça,
eh bien, s'ils voient qu'il y a des milliers, des dizaines de milliers, des centaines de milliers de personnes qui sont déjà là.
Après, là aussi, il peut y avoir des manipulations, des faux profils, des-- bon, mais on va peut-être pas rentrer là-dedans.
Mais, disons, le nombre, ça compte beaucoup et ça permet, une fois qu'une idée a rejoint une certaine masse critique, ça abat les résistances.
Et là, du coup, ça peut circuler très largement, même dans des mondes qui n'étaient a priori pas disposés à avoir des idées aussi radicales.
En plus, ils ont pu aussi, par rapport aux sondages online qui sont effectués après les débats, qui étaient effectués après les débats présidentiels,
là aussi, dans les sondages traditionnels faits par téléphone, Trump sortait en général pas en première position.
Mais dans les sondages online qui étaient effectués immédiatement et en même temps, par rapport au déroulement des débats télévisuels entre les candidats républicains et puis avec Hillary Clinton,
Trump sortait gagnant grâce
beaucoup à ses supporters, justement, sur Internet.
Et ça aussi, ça a créé un effet psychologique important parce que Trump pouvait tweeter immédiatement : « On a gagné, les sondages disent qu'on a gagné, on est les premiers », etc.
Donc ça a vraiment créé un effet un peu d'avalanche, d'un certain point de vue.
Très bien. Patrick, tu avais une question ?
Non, peut-être une remarque, quand on parle du mouvement Gamergate, je viens de retourner sur mon blog regarder la date à laquelle j'ai écrit ce fameux article.
Et c'était en octobre 2014, donc on est à cinq ans du mouvement Gamergate. Je pense qu'on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui, le Gamergate est devenu quelque chose de, comment dire, de minoritaire.
Le mouvement et ses membres n'ont pas disparu. Ils continuent à s'agiter de temps en temps, mais il y a une réaction
assez vive de rejet de ce mouvement et de ses idées, qui a pris un moment, parce que c'était complètement chaotique, on revient au sujet dont on parle,
de la part de la communauté des gamers dans son ensemble.
Et au bout de deux, trois ans, les choses ont commencé à se calmer. Et aujourd'hui, il y a toujours ces idées qui sont agitées par certains d'entre eux, mais je pense que ça a peut-être même permis de mettre au jour des problèmes,
qu'ils ont symbolisés et qu'on essaye aujourd'hui de gérer dans la communauté des gamers.
Donc la raison pour laquelle je dis ça, c'est qu'à cinq ans du Gamergate, le phénomène est, on va dire, maîtrisé. Peut-être que dans le monde politique et social en général, l'ampleur est plus grande, donc ça prendra plus de temps.
Mais peut-être qu'on a de l'espoir, effectivement, comme le disait Giuliano. Peut-être que ça va prendre un peu plus que cinq ans,
mais qu'on réussira aussi à canaliser cette idéologie qui semblait tellement chaotique et qui semble tellement immaîtrisable, et qui était de la même manière immaîtrisable au moment du Gamergate.
Donc peut-être une petite note d'espoir.
Un avis là-dessus, Giuliano ?
Ah oui, tout à fait. Non, mais moi, je suis persuadé que ces phénomènes évoluent, et qu'il y a, bon, il faut travailler dessus.
Il y a un travail qui peut être fait au niveau de la régulation aussi, par exemple. Mais là aussi, je suis plutôt optimiste.
C'est-à-dire, quand on parlait il y a simplement trois ou quatre ans de régulation des plateformes, des réseaux sociaux et cetera, bon, c'était un discours tout à fait inaudible, absolument minoritaire.
Aujourd'hui, c'est un thème qui est sur l'agenda, au centre de l'agenda politique. Il y a des candidats à la présidence des États-Unis qui ont dans leur programme,
de réguler les plateformes et même de casser certains monopoles.
Il y a une question de concurrence aussi qui est une question importante. On a vu ce qui est en train d'être fait quand même au niveau européen.
On est encore très loin d'arriver à une vraie régulation de l'écosystème informatif sur Internet, mais on est en train d'y arriver.
Et donc, à plusieurs niveaux, le débat évolue. C'est très visible par rapport justement seulement à il y a trois, quatre ans.
Et je pense qu'on trouvera des solutions. Mais je disais, on trouvera des solutions de régulation pour limiter les abus,
et pour responsabiliser un peu les plateformes par rapport au contenu qu'elles véhiculent, parce que, mais elles ne peuvent quand même pas être tout à fait irresponsables par rapport à tout.
On l'a vu dans le cas de la tuerie, par exemple, en Nouvelle-Zélande. Bon, il y a quand même encore beaucoup à faire.
Mais ça évolue d'un point de vue social, politique aussi, de la réponse qui est donnée, de la traction même, comme le disait Patrick, que ces mouvements ont.
Parce que c'est vrai, après, que tout ça, c'est quand même un peu plus difficile à faire une fois qu'on est au gouvernement.
On a vu dans le cas italien que, par exemple, la popularité du Mouvement 5 étoiles a dramatiquement baissé au cours d'une seule année.
Ils sont passés de 33 % aux élections de 2018 à,
à 17 % aux élections européennes du mois dernier. Bon, après, en Italie, c'est particulier parce que c'est Salvini qui monte, donc ce qui n'est pas nécessairement mieux et peut-être même un peu pire. Mais-
Y a un an, justement, à l'aube de ce gouvernement italien, donc la coalition, on le rappelle, entre la Ligue de Salvini et le Mouvement 5 étoiles, vous prédisiez il y a un an que ce gouvernement,
il n'allait pas durer cinq ans et qu'il allait certainement se planter en cours de route.
Aujourd'hui, est-ce que c'est toujours votre sentiment ? Comment est-ce que vous voyez la chose ?
Oui, il ne va pas durer cinq ans. Là, la question, mais on rentre dans la politique italienne, c'est que Salvini va à un certain moment vouloir prendre le contrôle.
Aujourd'hui, il est majoritaire en termes de votes, mais il est encore minoritaire à l'intérieur d'un gouvernement qui a été constitué dans une situation différente.
Donc, il va vouloir probablement, à un certain moment, passer par de nouvelles élections, pour, avec une nouvelle coalition dont il serait le guide.
Et s'il gagnait les élections, il deviendrait Premier ministre en Italie. La question de ça, ce n'est pas une question de
si ça va se produire, parce que ça va se produire, mais c'est une question de quand, c'est une question de timing.
Et le timing, il est assez largement remis à Salvini lui-même,
même si, en Italie, il y a quand même un problème de finances publiques, de rapport avec l'Europe, donc de formation de la loi de budget à l'automne, qui est toujours un thème très délicat.
Et donc, il va falloir que Salvini considère ça aussi. Mais tôt ou tard, la coalition va se briser et Salvini va essayer de prendre le pouvoir directement, seul.
Oui, mais là, comme vous le disiez, c'est un cas un petit peu particulier, puisque d'habitude, quand on est au pouvoir, on a tendance plutôt à baisser dans les sondages.
Et là, Salvini, il arrive à monter. Donc c'est très particulier. Mais si on prend un autre exemple, hein, par exemple, je sais pas, un Viktor Orbán ou un,
ou un Donald Trump, donc voilà, des figures plutôt antisystème, ou en tout cas, c'est comme ça qu'ils se positionnent.
Quand on arrive au bout de son mandat, et que voilà, c'est-- en l'occurrence, pour Donald Trump, c'est plutôt quelqu'un de, on peut le dire, plutôt quelqu'un d'incompétent.
Est-ce que quand un leader, voilà, qui se positionne sur ce national-populisme, sur cet anti-establishment, est-ce qu'un leader est sanctionné pour son incompétence ou bien est-ce que ça n'a aucune importance ?
Disons, l'incompétence, paradoxalement, est devenue un
argument en faveur de ces leaders, parce qu'elle prouve qu'ils n'appartiennent pas au système, qu'ils n'appartiennent pas au monde des vieilles élites, qu'ils ne sont pas,
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un technocrate, qui donc,
d'un point de vue électoral, c'est plutôt un argument
en faveur de ces leaders que contre, ce qui est un paradoxe, mais c'est comme ça.
Alors après, une fois au pouvoir, évidemment, l'incompétence, elle provoque des dégâts, elle provoque des gaffes, mais elle provoque aussi des-- bon, ça peut devenir dangereux.
Mais encore une fois, la grande capacité de ces leaders-là, et ça a été le cas de Trump comme celui de Salvini, c'est de cibler leur base.
C'est-à-dire, ce qui est prioritaire pour eux, c'est de continuer à envoyer des messages qui vont motiver et fidéliser leur base.
Ils la connaissent très bien, ils savent exactement quels sont les arguments qu'il faut utiliser pour ça. Et donc, ils vont toujours
avoir la priorité d'envoyer des messages qui n'ont rien à voir avec la compétence, la gestion économique, etc.
Mais c'est vraiment de la propagande,
et donc des symboles.
Et là, justement, la bataille de Trump pour avoir le financement de son mur, même si ça a provoqué l'arrêt de l'administration fédérale,
les, la bataille que Salvini fait contre chaque bateau d'ONG qui débarquerait en Italie.
Et en concentrant toutes ces énergies, non pas sur la solution du problème migratoire,
mais sur les quarante migrants qui sont à bord du navire spécifique sur lequel il va faire une semaine de campagne de communication haineuse, etc.
Donc, on est en dehors de la réalité. On est dans la pure représentation politique, symbolique, etc. Mais ça reste quand même très efficace sur la base des électeurs de ces personnages.
Et apparemment, par exemple, dans-- encore une fois, dans le cas italien, sur une base même plus large, hein. On est vraiment plus dans le théâtre que dans la réalité.
Après, pour que la réalité morde, ça prend plus longtemps. Hein, on est en train de voir ça, par exemple, en Italie, dans les villes.
La-- Rome, qui est gérée par un maire cinq étoiles tout à fait incompétent. Aujourd'hui, les citoyens sont très mécontents parce que ça se passe très mal, hein.
Mais dans une ville, il a fallu quand même plus que deux ans. Et dans une ville, les résultats pratiques d'une mauvaise gestion, on les voit beaucoup plus tôt.
À un niveau national, vous êtes Premier ministre, ministre, etc. Pour qu'on perçoive les dégâts et les mauvais résultats de votre gestion dans la vie quotidienne des gens, ça prend beaucoup plus de temps.
Donc, malheureusement, la propagande a vraiment un énorme rôle à jouer.
Oui, oui, donc c'est effectivement cette promesse d'être antisystème, ben, finalement, elle est tenue par les Donald Trump et autres, puisque voilà, ils font un shutdown du gouvernement, etc.
Et donc c'est une promesse tenue et qui parle particulièrement à leur électorat. Très bien, mais on a bien dépassé les septante minutes que nous devions passer ensemble.
Donc, je vais vous remercier tous les deux d'être venus. Giuliano, merci beaucoup, encore une fois.
Merci, c'était très agréable et très intéressant.
Et on peut vous retrouver sur Twitter, donc Giuliano da Empoli, tout simplement en cherchant. Et je mettrai le lien dans la description.
Et donc, on le rappelle, vous avez publié un livre il y a un an qui s'appelle Les ingénieurs du chaos où, voilà, vous détaillez tout ce que vous avez expliqué ici aujourd'hui en allant encore plus en profondeur.
Et donc, c'est publié aux éditions Jean-Claude Lattès. Autre chose à promouvoir ?
Non, ben, c'est tout pour l'instant. Je suis en train d'écrire la suite, mais ça prendra quelque temps.
Ben, oui, on a presque envie d'espérer que ça n'arrive jamais puisque la suite sera, je suppose, très sombre.
Non, non, non, la suite, ce sera plutôt les mouvements et les cas qui arrivent à contrer les ingénieurs du chaos. Donc elle est un peu plus positive.
Ah effectivement, effectivement, c'est plutôt lumineux. Patrick, où est-ce qu'on peut te retrouver ?
Oh ben, sur Twitter également, Notes Patrick. C'est très très simple. Vous l'avez déjà retenu, Notes Patrick en un mot. Et puis sinon, en podcast avec le Rendez-vous Tech qui étudie les sujets tech divers toutes les semaines.
Ou alors, tu évoquais The Phileas Club, qui est Phileas comme Phileas Fogg, hein, du Tour du monde en quatre-vingt jours.
Mais le plus simple, c'est d'aller sur frenchspin.com et de trouver l'orthographe, où on discute avec des gens de tous horizons et de tous bords,
et on essaye justement d'avoir des vraies conversations et pas juste de s'envoyer des conclusions au visage.
Donc, si ça vous intéresse, c'est en anglais par contre. Le Rendez-vous Tech est en français, mais The Phileas Club est en anglais.
Très bien. Mais justement, le Rendez-vous Tech, c'est précisément parce qu'il y a quelques mois, un de tes auditeurs, en fin d'émission, avait
fait la promotion du livre de Giuliano, en expliquant justement que Les ingénieurs du chaos étaient parvenus à reconvertir le,
les Gamergaters en un électorat pour Donald Trump, que j'avais compris : « Tiens, ce livre a très certainement compris quelque chose puisqu'il a saisi cet aspect-là.
» Donc c'est grâce à toi, en fait, que j'ai pu lire et apprécier-
Grâce aux auditeurs
...le livre de Giuliano. Oui, oui, c'est vrai, mais indirectement, indirectement grâce à toi, Patrick.
Merci.
Je mettrai aussi le lien dans la description vers ton article sur le Gamergate. Et on l'a pas dit, mais tu étais l'invité de ce délicieux podcast il y a un an, tu étais venu.
Donc, je mettrai le lien aussi vers cet épisode-là.
Super.
Merci à tous les deux.
Merci.
Et c'était un plaisir de vous écouter. Et chers auditeurs, on se retrouve dans deux semaines. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
C'est déjà tout pour cet épisode avec Giuliano da Empoli et Patrick Beja. N'hésitez pas à me dire si ça vous a plu. C'est le genre de sujet qui me fascine, mais voilà, je sais que ce n'est pas la tasse de thé de tout le monde.
Encore une fois, cette émission s'appelle Septante Minutes Avec. Elle aurait peut-être dû s'appeler Septante Minutes à la louche parce que voilà, visiblement, les épisodes d'une heure et demie sont de plus en plus fréquents.
Si vous découvrez ce podcast avec cet épisode, n'hésitez pas à vous abonner sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée, à nous suivre sur les réseaux sociaux et à nous laisser des étoiles sur Apple Podcast.
J'ai mis les liens dans la description. Dans un genre complètement différent, on a un peu parlé de jeux vidéo aujourd'hui.
Si vous êtes joueur, j'ai remplacé Patrick pour un épisode de son podcast Le Rendez-vous Jeux, où on a parlé du futur de l'industrie vidéoludique avec le streaming, les nouvelles consoles et les tendances qu'on a observées à l'E3 cette année.
J'ai aussi mis le lien dans la description. Promis, on arrête avec la politique pour le moment et on revient très vite avec des sujets plus légers. À très bientôt.